Olha só, você sabia que mais de 1200
pessoas tiveram a boca em chamas por
causa de uma pasta de dente? Pois é, a
Colgate mudou a fórmula da pasta total
12 e começou uma enchurrada de
reclamações, ardência, inchaço, aftas
que impediam até de comer e falar. A
Anvisa teve que proibir a venda mais.
Veja bem, o produto ainda ficou
circulando por um tempo. Como médico, eu
te digo, eles trocaram o tipo de flor na
fórmula e adicionaram novos
aromatizantes e corantes. Qualquer
mudança pode gerar reações em pessoas
sensíveis. E olha, eu vou te dizer uma
coisa, ninguém lê rótulo de pasta de
dente, não é? Seja sincero. E mesmo que
leia, não entende nada. Lauril, sulfato
de sódio, tricolosã, dietanolamina.
Parece aula de química. A gente usa todo
dia duas, três vezes e nem faz ideia do
que tá colocando na boca. Então fica a
dica. Sentiu algo estranho na boca? Pare
de usar na hora. E olha, deixei uma
lista de pastas com ingredientes mais
naturais para você conferir.